c'est un moment que tonnes la colère du
peuple français à la voix du procureur
général de la république des proches
française
dans son implacable réquisitoire
[Musique]
je signale à monsieur tomek à hennebont
il ya un château hôtel vachement bien la
publicité à bascule non mais c'est
rudement bien les mecs tu veux pas de
pompe et avec monsieur le président
chers maîtresse monsieur le représentant
des anciens gorille outre méditerranéen
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
chéri mon amour comme la tradition
l'exigé dans notre tribunal le prévenu
une fois de plus est accusé de n'importe
quoi car pour nous mesdames et messieurs
les jurés cher public fidèle qui vient
dé l'obsède lutiner aux portes de radio
france pour ne pas rater une seule
audience du tribunal des flagrants
délires c'est à croire que vous bossez
jamais les mêmes
incroyable sont toujours là pour nous
mesdames et messieurs band of mana
l'important n'est pas tant l'ampleur de
la faute de l'accusée l'important est de
trouver une matinée de libre dans
l'emploi du temps du bourreau or le
bourreau est débordée en france par les
temps qui courent
qu'est-ce qui écrit après encore heureux
que les sentences de mort épargne les
femmes ce en quoi soit dit entre
parenthèses on atteint ici le comble
paroxysmique de la misogynie
phallocratique et les glorieux sommet de
l'imbécillité machiste en effet de même
que les mâles se sont arrogés annoncé ce
pardon se sont arrogés studio de même
que les mâles de même que les mâles se
sont arrogés l'exclusivité de jouer à la
guerre au foot au tour de france au cap
les voici maintenant qui revendique avec
véhémence le droit exclusif à la peine
de mort la place de la femme n'étant pas
à la guillotine mais à la cuisine
fermons la parenthèse et y revenons à
nos moutons ânes au gorille ou plutôt de
quoi tu est pardon pardon de quoi
accuse-t-on nous roger hanin
d'infraction aux règles élémentaires de
l'hygiène parce que ça fait un demi
siècle qu'il a les pieds noirs et de
complicité de vandalisme puisqu'il est
apparentée de très près à l'arracheur de
rose de château chinon
oui monsieur le président je sais je
sais que la cour n'a pas retenu ce
deuxième chef d'accusation que j'avais
éructer en mon âme et conscience lors de
l'instruction
je signale à la cour que lorsque j'ai
suggéré d'accuser roger hanin de
complicité dans cette affaire de
vandalisme anti rozier le président
villers que je soupçonne entre nous
d'être un activiste pro giscardien
frénétique
le président villers a dit fais pas le
con si jamais mitterrand est élu tu nous
faut dans la merde le tout c'est pas
faire le con trop tôt quoi ça maintenant
il faisait soigner dans ce cas la
commissaire du gouvernement
je sais pas évident aux yeux rivés sur
la liste des premiers sont fusillés or
j'y reviens parce que c'est très grave
prenez garde si vous m'écoutez monsieur
mitterrand si vous continuez à arracher
trois mille rosiers tous les dimanches
pour votre folklore socialiste alors
même que brice lalonde et son amical des
chlorophyllien déchaîné passent leur
week-end à replanter du varech tu jusque
sous l'autoroute faudra pas trop compter
sur les voix des écologistes deuxième
tour en double je vous le dis parce que
je vous aime françois vous permettez que
je vous appelle françois
certains l'appellent françois d'autres
la pelle à tarte
c'est comme quoi c'est comme pour agatha
christie
certains l'appellent agatha donc la
pelle à gâteau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à ce stade de mon réquisitoire mission
président est allé le retrouver au stade
n'allait pas avec vos amis à ce stade de
mon réquisitoire monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les jurés monsieur
l'émotion qui m'étreint n'a d'égal que
les mois kim égard au temps autant vous
l'avouer c'est un très vieux rêve que je
viens de réaliser en dix ans certains
l'appellent agatha d'autres à la pelle à
gâteau
ça fait 30 ans que josé par voulez vous
en savoir plus oui bon puisque vous
insistez voilà alors que je préparais
douloureusement le baccalauréat dans un
lycée parisien dont je tairai le nom
pour ne pas faire de publicité au lycée
carnot
j'avais un professeur d'anglais
complètement coincé puritains
visiblement mal baisées du montant
variable
la malbaie c'est mixte je le signale en
passant onana immobiliste en amour s'il
y en a un qui rament pendant que l'autre
fait la planche on risque pas d'arriver
ensemble au paradis donc ce professeur
d'anglais était infiniment timoré timide
chafouin et boursouflée de complexe
multiple quoique sympathiques
il avait en outre une sainte horreur des
calembours moi aussi mais je me domine
or j'avais à l'époque un camarade de
classe un camarade de classe qui m'était
très proche puisque nous avons préparé
tous les examens ensemble dans ma
chambre avec des copines qui nous
faisait réciter
pas le look ne le crachoir qui me
permettent
et ce garçon et moi avions la manie des
paris stupides alors c'était du genre
t'es pas 6 de peloter la mère du
concierge qui pâtissent de chanter
l'internationale la messe de 10h t'es
pas chiche d'arracher la moumoute de
prof de chant des pastiches de répondre
un petit [ __ ] prof de lettres ça a été
jusque là et là c'était très mauvais
goût ça il l'a fait mon copain le
professeur de lettres en question était
un jeune agrégé noir guadeloupéens et
déjà c'est que je me rappelle encore
toute honte bue la brillante prestation
mon ami devant ce professeur
guadeloupéens ça lui avait valu un blâme
et à - 10 balles parce qu'il avait fait
le pari et savait de naissage sûr que
c'est vrai hélas vous la seconde vous là
vous pouvez nous rappeler dans quelles
circonstances les fleurs du mal ont eu
des démêlés avec la censure et la
justice oui mon ami sayan amitié
baudelaire lui écrire beaucoup
saloperies gouvernement lit pas compte à
ce jour là j'étais secoué de rire et de
honte en même temps tant il est vrai et
c'est horrible que plus c'est
dégueulasse plus c'est rigolo et que 2
you c'est pas parce qu'on est jeune
qu'on n'est pas des comptes ça les mecs
pour vous le dire je connais même des
jeunes chômeurs qu'on voit c'est
incroyable de paris des bilans pari
stupide
il était normal sachant à quel point
notre professeur d'anglais était
allergique aux calembours douteux que
nous parions un jour je parle de notre
province sud avant que nous parlions un
jour d'en lâcher un calembour
particulièrement gratiné dans sa classe
et comme à l'époque nous étudions les
aventures d'hercule poirot dans sa
version originale anglaise avec
interrogation écrite et commentaires
libres à la clé nous avions parié que je
préférerais un jour en place cette
véritable insulte au bon goût franco
britanniques constituent le i deux jeux
de mots complètement déshonorant dont je
parlais plus haut et que je n'ose même
plus répéter non non si aller
en effet les faits dimanche d'ailleurs
dimanche de pelle à gâteau la veille du
cours de littérature anglaise je dormis
mal en cauchemar des est la seule à la
seule idée que j'allais pour moins de
trente deniers trahir l'estiment de ce
professeur d'anglais qui m'aimait bien
c'est vrai tout temps ma ville hissant à
ses yeux et au mien propre et le
lendemain je me suis dégonflé je me suis
dit gonflé alors qu'aujourd'hui ce que
je n'ai pas osé dire devant un jeune
pédagogue
je ne crains point de le crier haut et
fort devant plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'auditeurs dont au moins cinq
mille professeurs d'anglais respectable
et intérêts certains l'appellent agatha
dante la pelle à gâteau
merci radio france merci france inter
merci à toi claude villers merci monique
des barbares merci aux techniciens du
studio 105 106 et à tous les techniciens
de france qui se relaient dans toute la
france afin que malgré le prix
exorbitant de l'énergie actuellement ma
voix des milliers et des milliers de
fois répercutées jusqu'au fond de nos
plus lointaine province
ma voix puisse lancer au monde ce
message incroyablement démoralisant par
son peu d'intérêt et sa nullité
crétiniser certains l'appellent agathe a
d'autres qu'on appelle à gâteau
[Applaudissements]
avant de terminer je dirai que ce n'est
qu'un regret c'est qu'il me manque à
l'évidence une qualité fondamentale
roger hanin l'appel pudeur d'autres
l'appellent d'essence avait fait peu non
[Musique]